[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei sonnigen 33 grad präsentierte sich
das bundesheer genauer gesagt das
kommando schnelle einsätze am
freitagnachmittag in rossau dass die
vorführungen an der kühlen donau
stattfanden war unter den besuchern mehr
als willkommen
[Musik]
die eindrucksvolle leistungsschau des
bundesheers war auf mehrere stationen
aufgeteilt
von der abc abwehr mit ihrem neuen
löschfahrzeugen zu der aufklärungsdrohne
trecker bis zu den vorführungen der
wasserfall ausbildung
[Musik]
die besucher konnten sich hautnah ein
bild von den gerätschaften aber auch den
fähigkeiten des jahres machen
[Musik]
auch die militärmusik niederösterreich
und die trachtenkapelle ross satz waren
mit dabei und sorgten für die einleitung
des hauptamtes der anlass für das
aufgebot des bundesheeres war nämlich
die angelobung von knapp 500 rekruten
vier wochen nach den eindrücken und dem
abschluss der allgemeinen
basisausbildung gelobten die jungen
soldaten der republik österreich und dem
österreichischen volk zu dienen
[Applaus]
vor der beeindruckenden kulisse des
stifts dürnstein sorgte die militärmusik
niederösterreich mit dem großen
zapfenstreich und krönenden abschluss
[Musik]